foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
the petty Yeti
is upset that we actually have a
president that gives a about
liberal democracy and defending people
who want to defend their liberal
democracy oh you traitor you
happy Monday
Marjorie T the green is really upset I
would imagine that I'm gonna spend most
of my day today explaining to you
insurrectionists out there why
why it is a good thing that President
Biden made a surprise visit in Ukraine
today on President's Day
I'm gonna explain to you why it's good
for liberalism and why it's good for
Liberal democracy and that's why you
hate it oh I get it see every single
time you watch one of these
troglodytes
these moglodytes as I call them
these fascists these real America First
Nazis
trudge on our institution of democracy
and not only that institutions of
democracy around the world especially
when they're UN in Peril you know who
their enemy is
Marjorie Taylor Green's enemy is not Joe
Biden Marjorie Taylor is Green's enemy
is not zielinski
Marjorie Taylor green is allies with
Putin because their enemies are the same
democracy is their enemy they do not
want Liberty for all they do not want
equity and equality for all they do not
want justice for all
it's white supremacy
that's why she's an ally with Putin
because the enemy
or the the enemy of your enemy
is your friend in this case and she
loves Putin because Putin wants to
destroy and is actively trying to
destroy not only Ukraine's democracy
but democracy all around the world
that's what she really loves about him
oh my God he is committed he is
committed even to destroy himself
to destroy democracy that Putin that
Putin Aunt Putin
it's a thing it's and you're gonna see
it on full display
today you're gonna see it on full
display
all day long about how much they love
authoritarianism
all day long I mean she's even talking
about divorce she wants to she's gone
she'd go and she's going through a
divorce right now can someone
can can someone check for me and see
ah you
I don't like to use that well I like to
use that word I just don't like to use
it that often a lot of people get
offended by the word but I think I
believe I believe when I use it
directed towards her my aim my aim is
spot on what do you think
I don't know that there's too many
people who disagree with me on that
including including Marjorie Taylor's
green husband who is trying to actually
divorce her
just saying I'm just saying
so President Joe Biden shows real
leadership today
um shows real courage and strength too
and I don't know if you've seen the
video of zelinski and Biden walking in
Ukraine in Kiev
as the national uh raids and uh bomb
Raid Sirens go off and they don't flinch
he doesn't cower
he had taken away and whisked away
he doesn't stop his conversation he's
not scared of the air raid sirens
uh the word is is that Russia found out
that
President Biden was in Kiev and they
decided that they would launch some
missiles to make sure
some migs to make sure that the National
Air Raid Sirens would go off while he's
there
and it had no effect
not an effect at all
which is the reason why
I am a fan
of this President going to Ukraine on
President's Day to visit with the
president president of Ukraine I'll tell
you that
um Arthur Taylor green is also she's not
only upset that Joe Biden went to
Ukraine she's also upset that President
zielinski didn't wear a tie oh my God
you you it's almost like it's almost
like the guy
is in the middle of a hot war or
something right like I don't know
[Music]
it's almost like it was like wearing
trotting around in a suit president
zielinski that is trotting around in the
suit would send the wrong message to I
don't know the people who are trying to
fight for the Democracy that he that he
is elected to
so it feels I don't know it feels like
the one of the bravest presidents
right now in this in this world
zielinski I mean think about it the
guy's in a hot War he could totally
he could have totally tucked tail and
run in the very beginning protected
himself went to Poland went to a NATO
state
uh operated his presidency from there
until it was safe he did not do that
remember you remember a year ago you
remember it was a year ago Vladimir
Putin was gonna take Ukraine in three
hours remember this ah he's gonna take
it in three hours and that was that was
you know
what the Russians thought that's what
that's what Vladimir Hitler thought
excuse me Vladimir Putin thought
that he was just gonna walk into Ukraine
and they would hail him and he would be
their King and dictator and
authoritarian
that's not what happened we're still
here A year later
and there's been Devastation in Ukraine
Devastation war is always
especially a hot war is always
devastating
especially when you have a murderous
authoritarian like Vladimir Putin
attacking civilians
directing attacks and targeting innocent
civilians people who have nothing to do
with the war people are not fighting in
the war they're just trying to avoid
being dead
and this is this is who Marjorie Taylor
green thinks is strong
this is what Marjorie Taylor green sees
as strength
is Vladimir Putin killing innocent
civilians targeting people who aren't
fighting in the war
who are being who their countrymen are
fighting to protect them
and protect them from from an
authoritarian leader and a dictatorship
they don't want to be Russia
I mean that's the whole oh wait Ukraine
needs to be part of Russia and then the
lie that then the lie that the right
wing spreads around oh my God
this lie that NATO is the one
who instigated Putin get the
out of here with that nonsense and
if Donald Trump was President Donald
Trump if Donald Trump was he's not
president you idiots
there's a reason listen to me there is a
reason why Donald Trump is not president
of the United States and the reason why
he has no play
over what ukrainians do and don't do
and it's because of you
it's because your belief in democracy
why do you think the ukrainians are
fighting
do you think they're fighting they're
fighting because they hate Vladimir
Putin
no they're fighting for the choice of
Liberty
Putin Putin is only a flash in the pan
folks Putin will die
Putin will die he's gonna be
gone he's gonna take a dirt nap one of
these days
democracy does not have to die
it doesn't
it's up to us to defend it
and Marjorie Taylor green that selfish
thinks that everything
revolves around her
and her beliefs and what she believes
and what she thinks is right and wrong
all the marbles rolling around in that
empty skull of hers
doesn't have the capacity to understand
that there's something Beyond her
no Republican understands this why do
you think they're in the situation that
they're in
they do not understand
the importance of Liberty they just
don't get it
they believe in their freedom to oppress
your rights because it makes them feel
good now before they take their dirt nap
they're not thinking they're not
thinking of the future Generations
they're not thinking of the
possibilities
they're not thinking of what what is to
come
America is not the greatest it's ever
been it's not
it hasn't yet
there is a greater America in our future
folks
it's one that strives for the most
equity and inequality that we possibly
can get to progress towards the most
Liberty that we've ever seen in our
Republic
why do you think Ukraine's fighting it's
not because their democracy is perfect
it's not because it's oh well oh the
Democracy in Ukraine is a corrupt
democracy there's corruption everywhere
of course there is we're humans
you don't think you don't think
corruption is the human is a human
invention
is human nature
of course it is
we're only human we're not all perfect
especially individually we're not
perfect for damn sure
we're better together
we're better when we think about the
masses
we're better when we do something in
kind for our fellow humans
that's the whole point
the whole point
and they've lost the plot
on democracy and Liberty
because it's their own
their own selfish power
not just in the government but over us
that blinds them
but this is what happens
when you when you let delusion run
rampant
and the media is going to let delusion
run rampant oh baby in the next few days
oh my God the media is gonna turn loose
on delusion
how Joe Biden showed up and you they're
gonna buy the Republican stupid
talking point narrative Hook Line Sinker
guarantee it Garen T they're
probably doing it this morning I
actually didn't turn on the news this
morning because I didn't want to hear it
I I did not listen to me I did not
listen to the news today
I did not listen to the news but my
guess is the media this morning this
afternoon tomorrow the next day the next
day after that even when Joe Biden does
go to Ohio
they're going to say oh my God this is
horror this is this is bad Optics
they're going to be asking the press
secretary is it bad Optics that the
president of the United States went went
to show his support to Liberal democracy
around the world and didn't show up in
Ohio listen Governor dewine told
President Biden to off are you are
you did you not pay attention to three
days ago when I said the wine told Biden
to off
I got this off you that's what he
said I mean not so many words that's
that's if if I was dewine talking to
Biden that's how I would have said it
but I'm not the wine
I'm not a Republican
and yes last week I said Ohioans are to
blame you keep electing Republicans I
watched a clip of Sheridan Brown over
the weekend who is one of the only
Democrats that can get elected in Ohio
maybe democrats should learn a
lesson or maybe Republicans should learn
a lesson there might be some some give
way for some commentary but I want
Sheridan Brown
talk about Ohio his home state of Ohio
and the problem that they're having with
the tactics will look folks
I I feel
for Ohio for the chemical spill there
but it's not the only train deal
derailment that's happened not the only
one
it just so happened in that place with
that chemical at that time and those
people are going to suffer because of it
and the reason why is because of
deregulation
if you if you fundamentally don't
understand if you if you're
bitching about corporations and
capitalism you're not under you're not
understanding you're not understanding
what happened in Ohio
and your commentary is way off
is that does that company need to
step in you goddamn right
whatever the government needs to do
whatever we the the people need to do to
make them step in and make what what
wrong they did right I'm not saying I
disagree with that
but this this is not a result of
corporatism or capitalism folks
this is a result of deregulation
if you think if you think that greed and
power and money in this country
is going to self-regulate itself you are
a dumb that's what we're
for the people we the people
we're the government we are the
government I I cannot tell you how many
times I'm going to say this and I'm
probably going to say it a million more
we are the government It Is Us
and when we the people and I had someone
on Twitter say something like oh
Democrats are working really hard in
Ohio to get Democrats elected but the
rural areas Republicans are still voting
against their own interest yeah because
the messaging sucks
I don't know I don't know I don't know
how many times I am gonna have to spell
it out for you
your Democrats lose elections because
their messaging is horrible their
narrative is horrible it's horrible it
always has been if you want good message
and good narrative come here yeah my Pat
myself on the back sure
but it's a winning strategy
you want to win you want you
want Republicans to be in charge or do
you want someone who gives a about
their constituents to be in charge
because Republicans definitely do not
give a about their constituents
otherwise they would not have
deregulated emergency braking systems
when you're carrying toxic chemicals
what the did you think was gonna
happen
this is why Joe Biden
Nyx
the Keystone XL extension that's why
because there was there was no
alternative other than a spill happening
somewhere sometime in the future and it
wasn't worth it
so it was worth deregulating right oh
totally worth deregulating
and I have talked a lot about the spill
in Ohio
but I'm going to talk about the cause of
it
you can't you can't undo it right
there's something We're Not Gonna We're
not gonna be able to turn back time you
ain't got a time machine
you ain't gonna get back these these
people their lives you're not going to
give them back their normal situation
that they had before the Republicans
wanted to deregulate not only deregulate
the braking systems but absolutely
destroy the fact that American workers
run the railroads
I'm gonna talk about who the is to
blame here and it's not corporations
it's not capitalism listen capitalism
and corporatism in in all its forms no
matter what you want to say Democratic
Socialist socialist anti-capitalist
whatever you want to say out there
you're you're listen to me listen get
really close turn the up
okay
you're not gonna get rid of capitalism
you're you're let's let me let me say it
again
you're not
gonna get rid of capitalism
it's like the idea that we somehow are
gonna get rid of the idea of fascism
you're not gonna get rid of it
you can't kill an idea you cannot kill
an ideology you cannot kill a type of
economy it will always exist because it
has before
you're forgetting The Human Condition
foreign
corporations surviving capitalism
surviving fascism surviving
is only a form of Human Condition the
same way that the people in Ukraine want
to fight for their Liberty
that's why Marjorie Taylor Green's on
Twitter losing their minds because she's
got that taste of fascism right now Bush
got that real good taste of
authoritarianism
she loves it
okay
we have to be honest with each other
and we have to tell each other the
things
that rather whether you like them or not
and the truth of the matter is as long
as Ohioans I don't give a where
they're at what color they are what are
they real live in rule Ohio or not I
don't care if they're voting against
their interest or not I don't give a
if they're voting for Republicans
they're voting for Republicans they're
voting against the interest of the
people in that town and they
cause this and to say that Joe
Biden's not doing anything the wine told
Biden to off
he does not want his help dewine
wouldn't even want FEMA in the EPA there
if he could help it but he can't
help it
because of Federal Regulation he has to
play ball there but he does not have to
have to call for a state of emergency
and take Biden's help he doesn't he
won't he's a Republican
don't fool yourselves don't fool
yourselves into thinking that you've
done all you can do that there's no
changing what the current state is don't
bully yourself go ask go ask zelinski
we'll ask him
go ask him if it's worth giving up on
go ask him I dare you go ask anyone in
Ukraine
who's had their Town smashed their
family killed over an authoritarian
who's trying to take over their Liberty
he's trying to strip it away from them
with blood of their countrymen
go ask them if it's worth it
go ask them if they should give up
go ask him
so this where you're
like oh well people in the rural areas
don't give up there is a way
listen the people in the rural areas
that are voting for Republicans aren't
conservative
they're not authoritarians they're
voting they're voting on affiliation and
lies and delusion folks
that's that's what they're voting based
on lies and delusion Jesus Christ you
know how much commentary I have watched
this morning
on off-handed podcasts saying that NATO
is the instigator in the Ukraine Russia
conflict When Vladimir Putin is the one
who is committing war crimes
killing civilians get the out of
here with this nonsense
the Russian propaganda is easily leaking
into the brains of Americans and they're
transmitting it all over the internet
and you're standing around wondering
well I wonder I wonder why people in
rural Ohio are voting for Republicans
against their interests because they
don't know it
we're not loud enough
we do not have a national narrative in
National messaging that is good enough
to drown out the
now I know I keep patting myself on the
back and I know it feels like you're oh
Tony you're just
you're just trying to be somebody
listen
there's a narrative and messaging that
works
there truly is
and it will defend democracy
it will give us the ability
to change
our fundamental thought about democracy
in this country
it's not going to happen overnight
two hours at a time baby
two hours at a time
that's that's why I'm sitting here right
now today
I'm committed
and I know you are too because you come
here every single day
every single day you come here
to share the messaging to share the
narrative
to push it out into the universe
uh I had a lot of people
um give me some Flack
for um people calling me the The antifa
Rush Limbaugh the left
because I was talking about democrats
should gerrymander
um one of the people on Twitter that was
giving me an excuse about why Ohioans
vote for Republicans one of it was oh
well the Republicans gerrymander their
way into yeah
yep
that's what we should be doing in every
state that we can
and every Democrat everywhere in the
state legislator
should be pounding that message we are
going to gerrymander the out of
this state as soon as we get a chance
we are gonna gerrymander Republican
politicians in our state out of
existence
what do you think what do you think
they're gonna do
if Democrats would fight the fight that
is to be fought
not not to go on defense because we got
defense folks we got Mark Elias Mark
Alliance is one of the best defenders
that we have against this he's one of
the smartest attorneys in the entire
country on Election laws
we need some offense
we got defense
we're playing D we've been playing
defense for years against these
Now's the Time Now's the Time to get
some offense
now is the time
to push forward what we accomplished in
2022 by fending off a red wave the only
reason why they hold the house is
because of gerrymandering think what we
could do if we gerrymandered ourselves
Tony Jesus God you sound like one of
them what do you mean someone who's
willing to fight
someone who's willing to use democracy
to save democracy is that what I sound
like well count me the
they're trying to use our democracy to
destroy it until you until you
understand what they are doing you will
lose and you will be sorely
disappointed
that your strategy didn't work
foreign this is this is a civil war on
information it's an information Civil
War and we must fight it
and if you're not fighting it then okay
I get it I understand
it's not worth fighting for then
but the demonstration
this morning
at the present United States walking
through the courtyard
in Kiev with the president of Ukraine
who was in a hot War
when the air when the national air raid
sirens sound they don't flinch
there's no better sign there's no better
signal
that Liberty democracy equity and
equality
his word fighting for
it's worth fighting for
rather it's in a hot war in Ukraine
because they want their Liberty
and us
giving them the assistance that they
need
to beat back Putin that murderous
dictator
or if it's here in Ohio fighting on the
ground with messaging and narrative to
show the people of Ohio you voted the
wrong way are you pissed off about your
situation any innate democracy that's
causing that situation
they duped you
and because they duped you that's our
problem folks it's Monday
and I'm glad to have you it's the bottom
of the first hour
you know when we usually come back we go
to the shitless Roundup uh Gabe Sanchez
is still traveling so he will not be Joe
I know I know I know
I know but he's he's not gonna be
joining us today he'll be back tomorrow
with Texas Paul tomorrow and I think um
I'm trying to um communicate with Dr
Rachel bittickoffer it's been a while
since she's been on so hopefully we'll
have Rachel on this week sometime maybe
Wednesday or Thursday but Texas Paul
definitely tomorrow Gabe Sanchez
tomorrow
I want to thank everyone out there that
is on my patreon before I go to break
93. I I set a goal of 100.
as the first goal and you guys smashed
it
you guys smashed it into pieces I mean I
I figured it'd take it's several months
to get to a hundred but I totally
underestimated the best audience in the
world so I want to thank you for getting
so close so quickly to the goal of 100
we just need seven more members over on
the patreon and we reached the goal of
100 and I but I want to thank all of you
rather you're the next seven or the next
50 or the next hundred or the the first
93 I want to thank you for your support
as a member over on patreon but more
importantly I want to thank all the
audience
all the audience for your support coming
here every day and listening this is
free it's free to listen
doesn't cost me oh my gosh me some time
and use some time but it doesn't cost us
a thing
so even if even if you can't afford to
go over to patreon and support me there
support me here
get in the chat get in the comments go
to my social media go to
thetonymichaels.com you can find all the
social media links there
you can share it around share this link
on YouTube you know what it's free to
subscribe
to YouTube so describe to subscribe to
YouTube channel we're trying to get the
20 000 we're over 14 now
you can follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and you can download every
single episode on Apple's Spotify and
Google it's free over there too
and I just appreciate all your support
whether it's likes shares comments in
the live chat whether you're a member on
patreon or not I appreciate you
and you are part of the em fam
but let's let's do this let's make sure
our messaging and our narrative is on
point to save democracy everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
what the is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
do not have Gabe Sanchez here today you
know I think we'll do
I think what we'll do is we'll go to a
ask Tony I don't know what we call it
and we did this last week during the um
during the show so what we'll do for the
next I don't know 30 minutes till the
top of the hour because I want to get to
this Marjorie Taylor green thing because
I believe I believe this idiot
is the poster child
the poster child
of this delusion that Vladimir
Putin is our friend and Ally poster
child for it
whew queuing On's a hell of a drug oh my
God
um
uh it's q9 world you're just living in
it we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life I don't know
how many ways I got to say it but
I got a lot of ways on how to say it so
we'll get to the petty Eddie don't worry
we will get to the petty Eddie and her
tweets and we'll get to the video
because this is this is the video that I
want to show you today the video that is
most important today is the video of
zelenski and Biden walking through the
courtyard as the National Air Raid
Sirens are going off so most one of the
most important videos You'll watch of
our present the real present a real
leader
show you what real leadership looks like
dewine hey governor dewine
maybe pay attention today maybe you'll
find out what real leadership
looks like
oh oh um
someone uh is it you know Margie says uh
sent me a message here she says shooting
the that's that's a good one that's
a good one how do you guys like that for
this segment where you know it's you
guys ask me comments in the um
in the chat because get your comments
ready get your questions ready here
because I'm going to answer some of your
questions we're going to interact in the
the chat here
um so make sure you have your questions
ready for what I think I know some
people are going to probably ask about
Jimmy Carter
some people are going to ask about maybe
Trump's legal woes
some other things maybe about uh I don't
know did you hear about this Carl Malone
thing holy
holy you know everyone's
saying shooting uh shooting the is
perfect
shooting the that's pretty good
that's pretty that's pretty good
I know my Margie's the one who'd come up
with that or she just uh stole that I
know she would admit it if she saw
someone because what happens sometimes
is the model sent me a DM
because they see something in the chat
so they're trying to alert me because
um when I when I go through the chat
when I see the chat on my end I see
everyone's chat so YouTube both Facebook
pages are there
um the the twitch channel it's all there
it's all
it's all there someone says kickers
oh we could do kicking the shoot
the kicking the I don't know
shooting the sounds good because
it's you know shoot the
now
all right here we go Greg's got another
straight shooting
[Laughter]
uh so get your questions ready we're
gonna answer them ask me anything you
want right now in the chat and I'll pick
out a few questions here uh Jared B
it says what happened with Malone
or excuse yeah Jared B on YouTube said
what happened with Malone
well apparently that Karl Malone is
going to be a big huge
um part of the All-Star Game in the NBA
uh all-star weekend is a big weekend
uh for the NBA it's where they get all
their best players in one game and they
get to do a bunch of dunking and
showboating
uh and apparently Carl Malone is going
to be a big part of it now Carl Malone
is an okay I knew that
um the one reason why I know that Carl
Malone is an is because
especially in the 90s in the late night
and early 2000s even the NRA used him as
their their black token
celebrity gay right the NRA was like and
he he was a proud member of the NRA
so I knew he was an right he's
always been an now I'm not
really sure of Carl Malone's stance with
the NRA now like if he's you know
official or non-official spokesperson or
even if he's a member anymore maybe
maybe he gave up on the NRA
because they're just a Russian
laundry money laundering machine
I don't know I don't know I couldn't
tell you that for sure but I know Carl
Malone is an from the get-go
but um this morning here maybe I should
just show this this clip
um of this show of someone who knows
Carl Malone
and then you can you can make your
decision I'm not gonna play the whole
clip and I don't need to play
the whole clip listen to what listen to
what they said this is a game theory
by Bo Jones what are your thoughts on
Carl below being a huge part of all-star
weekend
you could basically make this question
what are your thoughts about Carl Malone
and stop it right there like it doesn't
have to be an occasion because I hated
Carl Malone so much before I had a great
reason I only had good ones like just
being a dirty player elbowing people all
the time you know that sort of stuff and
then you know we find out the whole
thing if you don't know this that when
he was in college Carl Malone had a baby
with a 12 year old
what the did you hear that Karl
Malone had a baby with a 12 year old
apparently when he was in college he
impregnated I didn't I did I didn't
know that I was eight years old when I
found out Carl Malone impregnated
a 12 year old what the so that's
what's going on that's what's going
that's the problem that Carl Malone's
gonna have now comb loan is kind of like
an under the radar type guy right like
he's not out there you know making big
deals about and all kinds of crazy
stuff right he's not like a spokesperson
and doing PSAs and in public and he's
just not he's retired
I mean
foreign
why if he knows that this is a situation
that's gonna
you know Fester on the internet in
today's age why would Carl Malone even
show his face at the All-Star game
that's my question but whoa I did
not know that I did not I had no clue
and I don't know again I don't know who
it is I don't know what year it happened
it had been years and years ago which
doesn't matter
a 12 year old girl he impregnated a 12
year old girl when he was in college so
he had to be over 18.
what the I did not know that
no clue
what the okay so um that's what's
going on with Carl Malone to answer your
question here uh another question here
let's see
hey Tony Will Roger Stone ever see
accountability for being a treasonous
box I believe he will Scott
the reason why I believe that
ronderstone is going to um
get hammered did you guys see the um oh
what the his name I forget his
name he he's he's the uh campaign guy
for Rand Paul and Ron Paul and Mitch
McConnell
who
um took Russian money to give it into
the Trump campaign he got sentenced to
18 months
he also received a pardon from Trump for
other campaigns Finance that he
other laws that he broke federal
laws he broke you gotta pardon from
Trump I wonder I wonder why I wonder
what he could have done to pay to get a
pardon from Trump
could it be could it be that he
got Russians to put their money into
this game bad on them I don't know but
um
um that guy received 18 months and he
received a presidential pardon so yes do
I think Roger Stone and Mike Flynn and
some of these others that have received
a presidential pardon from Trump or seek
the presidential pardon from Trump
because they're treasonous species of
are going to see their day yes I do
um you don't see Mike Flynn and you
haven't heard of Roger Stone getting
getting
um subpoenaed by
the grand jury of Jack Smith the special
counsel for a reason I believe I believe
because they're the targets hmm and when
you're a target of someone like Jack
Smith who prosecutes war criminals
around the world oh boy that is not a
position that I would want to be
in now oddly wired on YouTube says ask
I just want to know if Tony has any pets
yes I do we have a dog
we have a dog
he's a dog
but I grew up with a lot of animals I
grew up on a farm actually in Central
Missouri close to the Lake of the Ozarks
very very close
uh so close in fact that I actually swam
in the Lake of the Ozarks almost every
weekend during the summer
um almost every single weekend so yeah I
I've had a lot of pets in my life a lot
of dogs a lot of cats we had cattle we
had chickens
so um I I've been around a lot of
animals in my life so but yes we do have
a family dog we do have a family dog
let's see what other questions do we
have here they're shooting the with
Tony I like this I like this shooting
this
everyone's saying what the over
Carl Malone isn't that crazy ass
the I did not know that again I
knew he was an
I knew that
I had no idea
and no idea
oh
and how how the NBA and anyone
associated with the with the All-Star
Weekend didn't realize that was gonna
wasn't that gonna what the
is there a chat on patreon for Tony
James is answering questions he's asking
Margie
is there a chat on patreon for Tony so
yeah so if you come over to patreon just
go to the Tony michaels.com and you can
actually and you can message you can DM
me on patreon if you're a member you can
DM me like patreons lets you do that
so once you become a member over there
it lets you DM me and I respond to you
and you can comment on any of the posts
that I post over there and you can
comment on any others uh any other you
know
person's comment we talk to each other
over there yesterday I posted because I
was a little late getting out the Sunday
rant yesterday on patreon and I did it
live I'm trying to try different things
over there
um so I did it live yesterday on a on a
private listing but I will
um
I I will say that I kind of like it over
there because I yesterday I told
everyone on patreon that it would be a
little late that I was busy that day and
then I asked him how their day was going
and everyone commented it was great some
people were were making lamb some people
were were planting their Garden I mean
it was um it was great to hear from
everybody so go go check out patreon
just go to the Tony michaels.com click
on the patreon link and you can go check
it out over there
what else do we have we got 15 more
minutes here
um any more questions
again it is hard to find some of these
do
it's kind of sometimes it's because
again I got a lot of
um
Jan wants to know if my dog is a Santos
rescue no he is not a Santos rescue
um he's not I mean I guess he kind of a
rescue dog maybe I don't know what
happened was is a friend of ours his mom
got the dog
and he did not acclimate to their dog at
all
so like like didn't you know they just
didn't get along
so she couldn't keep him as a puppy so
we took him since um since they couldn't
and we were looking for a dog at the
time so it worked out perfect I guess uh
Wendy asked
have you ever had paranormal paranormal
experience near the Ozarks no I know I
don't have are you talking about ghost
Wendy
we're doing my ghost I have never
experienced ghost no
I've never experienced that I I I'm not
very superstitious at all
um I'm an atheist so I really I don't
get you know I don't pay attention to
much stuff uh like that
uh
let's see
what's happened I missed it oh that it's
the Carl Malone thing
ooh baby you don't um
you don't wanna no you don't want to
know too much about it other than Carl
Malone got a 12 year old pregnant while
he was in college
that's right Carl Malone the basketball
player of the Utah Jazz and later the LA
Lakers that Carl Malone that guy the
famous gang got a lot of money shooting
the basketball and dunking the
basketball
he got
a 12 year old pregnant while he was
in college
damn
uh let's see
here's another one
from twitch will the full extent of
Trump's crimes ever be fully exposed yes
it's going to take a long time uh well
and it you know it's kind of up to Trump
too I'm not going to say it's not up to
Trump
I mean the reason why we know the crimes
that he committed with the documents is
because he said it he said it out loud
right
so I mean I don't I don't know
I don't know
um a vet says Facebook she says do you
think Fox News is going to be held
accountable by Jack Smith
are you talking about like the January
6th
listen
um I don't believe that Fox News is
going to be criminally liable for
January 6th if that's what you're
talking about if you're talking about uh
Fox News lying
to Their audience gaslighting Their
audience and getting them you know
yeah if you're getting it I I I think
you're you're far-fetched to believe
that that might happen
now I don't know if you noticed over the
weekend but Fox News
is probably going to be held accountable
for the Dominion case
is it going to burn Fox News to the
ground probably not Rupert Murdoch is
one of the richest men in the world
no case against Dominion is going to
kill Fox News it may change them
fundamentally let's hope but I doubt it
I don't know if you saw some of the text
messages but even even the people who
were spreading the lies didn't believe
them themselves which
it's kind of on brand for these
it's on brand form
there's shanks
they're Shameless
they're a death cult what do you expect
from them
but I doubt that Fox News is going to be
held accountable or criminally liable
for anything that happened on January
6th
I mean the best we can do to hold them
accountable
the best we can do to indict Fox News in
this country is to be louder than they
are
that's what I keep saying we have to be
louder than they are we have to spread
our message we have to have a better
message and a better narrative
I mean believe that we're going to turn
Trump supporters into Biden supporters I
don't believe that
not for a second
but over the next 10 or 20 years and and
that's the that's the long battle we're
at here folks I'm not talking about next
month this is going to change
I'm talking about we're gonna have to
pound the drum for decades and decades
to change this to turn this around to
make sure that fascism crawls back
underneath its Rock it's not going to
happen overnight I mean fascism was
always here
it was always here and it was always
thin veiled
with the word conservative
it's always a lie I'm conservative
now you're a fascist
you're a fascist
conservative once want to conserve
status quo
they don't want to take away rights from
people they don't want to deny rights
that people have currently
it's not conservatism a conservative
want to conserve those rights for the
people they had they just wouldn't want
to extend to any new people and they
wouldn't want to they wouldn't want to
make more rights for more people
when I conserve the ones they have these
people want to take away people's rights
they want to tell you what the
you're supposed to believe
it's that conservative they haven't been
conservative for a long time they've
been veiled it right there's a lot of
never trumpers out there
a lot of former quote Republicans
who hate Trump who are
anti-trump uh Lincoln project is one of
the groups that has a shitload of of
never trumpers or
anti-anti-trump Republicans or Former
Republic whatever the
label you want to put on them
but they thin veiled their fascism as
conservatism for years and perpetuated
this
that's why I was talking the other day
about Rush Limbaugh and why the left
needs someone who can stand up and do
what he did for fascism they can do it
for democracy
I don't know if I'm it I don't know if
I'm the one that can do that for
democracy I'm damn sure gonna try
and if me compare if someone comparing
me and then me saying it out loud then
I'm not embarrassed that they're
comparing me to rush what Rush Limbaugh
did for fascism is what I could do for
democracy well then fine I'm okay with
it you think I wouldn't be okay with
that
do you have any idea fundamentally what
Rush Limbaugh did for fascism in this
country it is the reason why we are
where we are
you think you think right-wing
conservative media just itself out
with Trump no it was born with Rush
Limbaugh on Fox News
come on
don't kid yourselves this stuff is not
new
this is like this is like a bunch of
bigots sitting around acting
like trans people are just oh it's a
brand new thing
those gays and those trans people that's
brand new it just happened in the last
couple years you are a dumb
if you think that is new
that is not new
now yeah do we know more because of
science because of medical advancement
do we know more about it
are are trans people able
to to identify as someone much easier in
society because of medical advancement
sure
absolutely but stay out of their
business
stay out of there it's none of your
business it's none of your
business you know I don't sit on
here and speak to how trans people feel
or what they want to do or I don't do
anything because it's not my business
it's not my business to tell them who
they are it's my business to
defend their Liberty that's my business
because if I defend their Liberty then
my Liberty is defended and in my
Liberties defended in my neighbor's
Liberty is defended
that's all we got to do that's it
that's why I fundamentally believe in
democracy and and if
if you're pissed off because I am
embracing the phrase Rush Limbaugh the
left
then you fundamentally do not understand
the history
of messaging a narrative in this country
and politics and what it's all about you
just don't get it yet and I hope I piss
you off enough that you come watch here
okay let's see
um more questions we got a few more
minutes here so you might find a few
more questions sorry I went on about a
tangent I knew that have you guys
noticed that
um
what's the dog's name someone asked what
the dog's name is
I'm not gonna tell you my dog's name
it's dog
uh do you believe in ghosts no sorry Tom
don't believe in ghost what's with these
questions
okay
uh someone asked uh will you host a zoom
chat for patreon members yes we are
going to do a patreon party for the
patreon members go check out the patreon
page and we're gonna do the first few
for like all members I think just give
you an idea because I really
honestly I don't know much about it or
how we're going to do it so I gotta
experiment a little bit
um
I'm gonna experiment a little bit but
let's see
there's some more com let's see oh
what's going down in Georgia besides the
devil
what what part of Georgia Greg I don't
know what you're referring to is there
something specific I don't know uh what
the George thing is I mean we were
talking about Ohio earlier
have I ever sharted in public and not in
public
no in a public bathroom you know you
know you know it happens it happens you
know I'm talking about naming
hey you know you can yeah it's Taco
Tuesday and you know they just don't sit
right it happens sometimes
let's see
shooting the with Tony
um
what other questions do you have I think
there's some more holy moly there's so
see that's the problem with this segment
and I'm gonna have to do this a little
differently
um that's who am I supporting for
Feinstein's seat
who am I supporting for Feinstein's care
well if I can
there it is maybe there he is who are
you supporting for Feinstein I don't
endorse any any candidates
I won't publicly or officially endorse
any candidates ever you're not yeah I
endorse democracy
so I believe here's what I believe Carol
that California will have
a very very very good
primary and it will come up with the
with the candidate that can win
California whether it be Schiff
or Katie Porter whoever it is whoever
the candidate is democracy will deliver
us that candidate
and all the supporters of the losing
candidates have to get behind that
candidate for democracy
and then the Democrat will win
Feinstein's seat
because there's only one party that is
willing to participate in democracy
and that is Democrats Republicans are
trying to destroy it so does that does
that answer your question
let's see
yeah I'm definitely gonna have to find a
different way to to do this
and when we have this segment there's
just so many
because again like I said I see all the
comments so it's hard for me to weed out
like the
it's hard for me to weed out the uh the
questions and the comments that's why I
put it on a delay but you guys you guys
comment and can't keep up
can't keep up with your comments
uh some people are saying Katie Porter
I I mean I mean I I think Katie Porter
Adam Schiff I mean
either one is going to be a good Senator
right
either one's gonna be a good sender uh
here's another question
um have you heard just today 45 said if
elected he would bring back the death
penalty yet he's doing this he's he's
stoking violence and what he's what he's
trying to do is get the Q and honors all
hopped up on hangings
and Michael from YouTube wants to know
this and what he's trying to do is feed
into this frenzy of of Q Anon Q Anon is
always from for years from the very
beginning talked about how they're going
to prosecute and hang they're going to
prosecute and hang people and
all that kind of and hangings
hangings this hanging they love lynching
Q Anon loves lynching the reason why q9
loves lynching is because Q Anon is bred
from white supremacy
again it's the angle that that white
Christian nationalists have used to mind
people into believing white
supremacist ideals by using it as a
conspiracy theory type thing and it's
with the lynching and hanging is so
that's why he's gonna say that more
often we should hang them we should hang
him he's just gonna keep going
um someone's asking what's my favorite
beer
Red Wave of ketchup
on YouTube wants to know what's my
favorite beer well I have to say my
favorite and you're just gonna piss a
lot of people off but my favorite beer
if I had to choose between a beer is
natural light but uh I don't I don't
drink a lot of beer anymore I used to I
don't drink a lot of beer anymore
um my my preferred drink is just a shot
of Jagermeister that might piss you off
too but there's there you go shooting
the with Tony they don't even want
to know
and you know um why we're talking about
shooting this on on patreon we're
going to do the um
we're gonna do an ask me anything over
there too so I I'll actually see all
your your questions and one of the tiers
we're going to ask me anything maybe
I'll do that this afternoon
maybe I'll do that this afternoon we'll
do an ask me anything over on patreon
I'll open it up to all members for the
first time because I again I gotta
practice I gotta know how to do stuff
over there because I'm not I'm not 100
sure
of every single little thing over there
so we're just experimenting
let's go one one more question let's
answer one more question
and then we'll uh we'll go to break and
when I come back we'll go to the um
the the uh Marjorie Taylor green stuff
Gregory from YouTube he asked
what made you get into politics Tony did
you see or hear that made you think
this
so
it's a good question great I've actually
been interested in politics for a long
time I've never hid this I I've talked
about it on a show before and I'll tell
this quick little story before we get a
break
my mom worked in state government here
in Missouri and um the uh the the state
government is very close to the federal
government and its structure the
Constitution is very similar in a lot of
different ways
um and and but when I was a teenager I I
I went to a garage I think I was 13
probably and I went to a garage sale I
didn't have a TV in my room we had
satellite on the TV in the living room
and when I was a kid we had the prime
star and then it became DirecTV but at
13 because we didn't get any channels of
size like three with the rabbit ears and
my dad got tired of that so he finally
they got Prime Star one Christmas
uh which again turned into DirecTV you
know that story and if you don't Google
it
but I didn't have a team in my room so I
founded a garage sale black and white TV
with the knobs on it
and I hooked up a pair of rabbit ears
and it was only strong enough to get one
channel
and I could watch the news at night and
I'd sit up and do my homework hey see I
was
I was a night owl I still am a night owl
but I would always I've
was a degenerate too I would always lie
to my parents and told them I had my
homework done I always did my homework
in my room at night when I was watching
the news and then Dateline with Ted comp
not Dateline
um Nightline Nightline with Ted gobble
that was the show would come on so I'd
watch the news I'd watch Nightline with
Ted Koppel while I was doing my homework
and then and then
um Bill Maher Politically Incorrect with
Bill Maher would come on
uh when I watched Politically Incorrect
with Bill Martin this was before Bill
Maher had real time as when he was on
network television you have a panel
against a lot uh at the time was like
George Carlin Larry Flint was a frequent
guest that's how I became Carlin and
Flint fans that's how I learned about
them learned about their interest in
politics and what their viewpoint on
politics and Liberty and freedom was
and then and then I'd watch Seinfeld
after they would run Seinfeld reruns so
I obviously a Seinfeld fan but I would
be doing my homework the whole time
but here I am 14 years old 13 14 15
years old sitting up in my room watching
Nightline with Ted Koppel and then
following up with Politically Incorrect
with Bill Maher and the thing about the
politically incorrect with Bill Martin
this is probably what sparked my
interest the most was watching
um personality sometimes commentators
sometimes comedians sometimes just
politicians but I watch them mock each
other and I watched the left mock the
right and I watch the right try to mock
the left and it never really did work
they weren't ever really able to mock
them and the reason why is because
logic defines their beliefs like it you
don't have to go very far
with rational thought
to bang up their beliefs and destroy
their thought process it doesn't take
much
but I understood that there was some
delusion that it took to be a Republican
or a conservative a lot of it was their
religion and their bias towards an
authoritarian bigger like a god
and so I learned a lot of that and
that's where I became interested in
politics and I followed it
ever since
um I get accused of hating Bernie
Sanders
by some younger folks that I know the
Bernie Bros
and people that I know personally and
I'm not talking about on the internet I
mean I mean I get I get some yeah you
hate burning on the internet
but people that I know
that were younger than me that um when
Bernie Sanders came along they became
Bernie Sanders lovers right they they
they
really followed this guy and they they
jumped on that bandwagon which I'm I'm
not I'm not
saying that's a bad thing I think any
movement towards more Liberty is good
but when Liberty is disguises or
authoritarianism I don't
I don't think that's a good message that
that ends up getting more authoritarians
that lean in the opposite directions uh
elected Nina Turner and tyt but anyways
I digress from that
and I I wanted to tell them like look
I've been watching Bernie Sanders since
he was a member of Congress before he
was a United States Senator okay so I
know who Bernie Sanders is and I know
what Bernie Sanders is and I know the
importance of Bernie Sanders in our
democracy I understand this very
important to understand
each seat is its own little institution
just like someone asked me earlier about
the Feinstein seat out in California
it's its own little Institution
and it's more important about what
fulfills the institution than who
right
sometimes to democracy especially in the
timeline and the part of history that
we're in it is more important about the
institution of that seat
in California then rather it's Katie
Porter or it's Adam Schiff
and it's very important to understand
the fundamental
institution of Bernie Sanders or AOC or
the squad it's very important to
understand that institution that they
are part of
then them in particular because again
we're all gonna take a dirt nap all of
us are going to take a dirt nap it's
just what remains once that nap begins
all right everyone stick around we'll be
right back with more the Tony Michaels
podcast we're gonna go the shitless
Roundup we're gonna give Marjorie Taylor
green some scorched Earth stick around
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part and blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
oh we're gonna
you guys ready to go Scorch Earth on
Marjorie Gainer green I
I'm ammo I'm gonna give you how to
handle this troglodyte the petty Yeti
I'm going to show you the perfect weight
on how to handle her yep that's what's
gonna happen I don't give a okay
let's start let's start with the
list Roundup because most of this is
just going to be Marjorie Taylor green
over the next 45 there's no way
there's no way I'm gonna spend
the next 45 minutes and not just
absolutely burn her down
for more reasons than just her comments
on Ukraine but
we'll see how it goes so stick around
you're going to want to stick around for
this uh first up I want to give some
Shameless plugs here everyone and go to
store.donymichaels.com Surf's Up
merch is available we got
t-shirts we got coffee mugs I promise
soon as the show has ended I'm gonna put
those hoodies up it was a busy weekend
it's busier than I imagined
when I told you I'd get hoodies up so it
happens I am I'm human like I'm the only
one here there
there's no one else here it's just it's
just me it's just me and Gabe Sanchez
was tied up this weekend with his
travels
so
and he's still traveling today but I do
want to give Gabe a shout out uh why
we're saying that you go over to what
was that
and visit Gabe on patreon at patreon.com
I am Gabe Sanchez for what was that like
I told you the other day my patreon is
for my additional content like the rants
the ask me a question the patreon
parties where we'll have Hangouts
um any exclusive videos Early Access to
social media Clips I do special posts
over there sometimes like I'll find a
meme and I'll post it there and comment
on it and I don't comment anywhere else
so if you want to see all that stuff you
can go to patreon.com
slash the Tony Michaels but get visit
Gabe's and mine Gabe's is for what was
that minus for my additional content
um and also while you're here subscribe
to the YouTube channel what are you
doing if you aren't subscribed to the
YouTube channel yet I know you are but
this is for the people who are watching
on replay but the algorithm feeds it too
I'm just trying to get it to them too
okay let's go to the shitless Roundup uh
before I get too far into this start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the show you've reached
the part of the show where we round up
all the Tweety tweets and the trendy
trends of today
boy do did Marjorie teether green make
the list today holy here it is
here's the verse here's one I responded
to
of course
I said you're dumb as dog I'm
referring to Marjorie it's either green
here of course
and I can't wait to talk about this
tweet on my show today
you should really come and listen Maybe
learn a thing or two
okay do you want to see this tweet
holy she is such a bonehead oh my God it
is no wonder this has one
bonehead of the week so many times like
she's always a shoe-in I think she's
only lost once and she didn't lose the
bone out of the week she lost in a round
of uh the bonehead in March March
Madness type bonehead that we have
she lost in a round I forget who she
lost to but
she's almost undefeated when it comes to
bonehead and this is just the
most boneheaded I've ever heard in
my life
okay here's what she says I'm gonna read
it to you and then I'm gonna break down
each little thing for you of why she's a
she says we need a national
divorce it really is rich
someone who who got her ass filed for
divorce on
you
to call for a national divorce this
really I keep telling you everything is
projection with these and
if you're not believing me yet God damn
you're not paying attention
wake up rub the out of your eyes
clean out your ears and pluck
your head out of your ass it's all
projection she we need a national
divorce who the is we
you mean you mean white people you mean
white people Marjorie Taylor
green that's exactly what she means
listen to her next statement
listen to the next one she's talking
she's talking about white States and
black States
doubt me on this you doubt me
she says we need to separate by Red
States and blue States that's what that
means by the way
that's that's what that means white and
black you know like race like she's like
I'm a white Christian Nationalist and I
want white Christian National Estates
and then we want woke States we want
black States is what she means that's
what she's saying you if you don't
think so you are not paying attention if
you don't know that's what she's saying
she says we need to separate by Red
States and blue States and shrink the
federal government what a idiot
so first she wants a natural divorce
from the federal government
you you are a dumb
What What In the how in the did did
she learn anything when she was
in Jesus Christ
she wants to divorce the federal
government she doesn't want to be part
of our country anymore but she wants to
shrink the size of our God you are a
dumb
Jesus Christ will you make up your
mind what stupid thing you're
gonna say would you please Jesus Christ
either you want small government or you
don't want to be part of the government
which is it dummy and then the whole we
need to separate by Red States and blue
States she's talking about segregation
folks segregated she wants to segregate
she's talking about white people and
brown people and black people she wants
to separate those things
that's what she's saying I want to have
white Christian nationalism in my state
and you woke motherwokers can go to your
state
she wants white States and black States
and she says everyone I talk to says
this every single bigot
get this
every single bigot that Marjorie Taylor
green talks to says this stupid can you
imagine okay can you imagine why every
single bit white ass Christian
nationalist bigot that she runs into
says this stuff I can't I can't even
tell you I can't even tell you
how how how much it warms my
heart that every single bigot that
Marjorie Taylor green green runs into
says this stupid oh my God it is it
just it's mind-blowing
it's mind-blowing that every single that
every single bigot that she runs into
says this dumbass about red States
and blue States look there's so much
more wrong with this than just the race
component I mean that's what that's what
it is it's about white Christian
nationalism
but folks
if if she got a national divorce
and we didn't have she wasn't part of
our government anymore it's called
Confederacy she wasn't part of our
government anymore
they wouldn't get our tax dollars and
what I mean by ours is the states that
pay more in federal taxes than they take
which I don't normally bore you with
Statistics and data
uh even even there's several studies out
there on the podcast showing proving
that I don't give you data and
statistics and polls I don't bore you
with that because that is
boring
but if you don't know
that the majority of the GDP in this
country comes from States
that generally have more Liberty and the
reason why they have more Liberty is
because the party that believes in
democracy actually hence power in those
States
you're not understanding how democracy
works and what it can deliver
and she clearly does not that's why she
wants to destroy it
here's the next point that she makes or
tries to make I should say she doesn't
make a point at all
remember when I said about the red blue
states that it's woke and Christian
nationalist remember that
here's here's
uh here's the woker part yeah she threw
the word woke in there she had to she
couldn't help her bigoted itself
she says from the sick and disgusting
woke culture issues black people
shoveled down our throats to the
Democrats trees in this America last
policies we are done good
good luck to you
good luck to you to be quite honest I I
mean you know this is really stupid at
its face we're in 2023 our nation has
the the fabric
that we have
um woven together by the state the state
to state our economy relies from state
to state especially when you have
certain States in this economy who take
more of the GDP than they give to the
GDP which I'm not against I'm not
against listen this idea that we should
we should leave a state hang out to dry
because they just don't have the ability
to contribute to the GDP like other
states I think that's
and it's but if we frame it up
in a certain way if we give the
narrative and the messaging the people
that reside in that state that vote for
its officials
might over a long period of time 10
years 15 years 20 years 25 30 years
will decide to start fundamentally
changing how they see their democracy
and start to understand
why they should vote in their own
interests not based on affiliation
it's just the thing that we should do
but you know again there's a lot of
stupid with this person's
thinking Marjorie Taylor green there's a
lot of that's wrong with this
person's thinking but the real issue is
is this bonehead
is part of our government she is part of
the government that she wants a divorce
from listen this is the problem that the
Confederacy had
the Confederacy had a problem with the
United States government
right and the problem was is they
weren't going to allow them to own
slaves anymore
that was the problem that they had
a lot of people probably including
Marjorie Taylor Green in the South lock
oh the civil war wound about slavery it
was about the economy
it was about States rats yeah it was
about the state's rights to let their
citizens own human beings
and and how how more can you define an
economical situation
then treating human beings as livestock
to provide labor slave labor how don't
you know that slavery was part of the
economy how don't you know that slavery
was the whole point of what rights the
states had that's what Lincoln was
saying listen you can be a part of the
Union but you don't get to own human
beings anymore
why don't you understand
you were fighting for the state's rights
to own slaves
but the problem that they had is they
couldn't participate in the government
that wanted to free the slaves
so they had to secede and start their
own Confederacy
and start their own government
hasn't quite coupled with reality
are battled with reality here yet
because she's not Tethered to it she's
just not Tethered to what is real I
can't even believe that this
is on the depart Homeland
Security committee
and this person doesn't even
fundamentally understand the Civil War
that we went through why we went through
it and why we are 50 states now
she doesn't get it she doesn't
understand the mechanism of why the
Confederacy left the Union in the first
place and she doesn't understand the
power of the Union
she just doesn't get it she won't get it
hey people in Georgia voting for
Marjorie Taylor green you're you are you
are dumber than she is
and this is what I'm talking about when
I say Ohio is to blame for the
derailment
listen if you in Ohio
wouldn't have voted for Republicans if
you would have a goddamn Democratic two
Democratic senators you'd have a
Democratic governor Federal help would
be already on its way
but dewine said no you I don't want
your help
and the reason why the wine does not
want the federal government's help is
because they don't want Joe Biden to get
the credit
I almost bet you a thousand
dollars that Donald Trump was losing his
mind
at the thought of Joe Biden
giving Ohio Federal money
because he would get credit
that's the whole game here is to box out
oh they're gonna own the libtards oh my
God Duane's gonna own the libtards by
making sure that no one get no Democrat
gets the credit
for cleaning up the mess I mean we're
gonna blame it on him we're gonna blame
it on Democrats but we're definitely
gonna make sure they don't get credit in
the meantime
because the fact of the matter is the
reason why the derailment and the
chemical spill in Ohio happened and it's
gonna happen again folks it's gonna
happen again
and again and again and again and again
and the people of Ohio only have the
people of Ohio to blame
it's you it is you it is us we are the
government
it is us we are the nation
we are the people what on what
on what in what
Constitution and what founding document
did you see some inanimate object
some some something that transcended us
humans as being our society and
our government it says We the
People
not King not authoritarian not a few
people who decide for us yeah was it
done under the guise of a bunch of rich
white landowners were we the people sure
but they left enough Elbow Room there to
get the 14th Amendment passed
which fundamentally changed what we the
people means
that's why they hate the 14th
amendment I don't know if you know that
that's why they hate it
well let's go to her other account
because as you know Marjorie Taylor
green has two accounts on Twitter
she's so important
and that's the fault of people Georgia
is the reason why she has two accounts
because she has official Congressional
account this is what she tweeted from
her official Congressional account
um I'm just getting news here that uh
it looks like we have 94 members on
patreon I want to thank you for again I
know this seems crazy but I I'm really
am it it makes my day my whole month
this whole year
the best thing that's happened
is that there and I know that sounds
crazy I thought it was going to take me
months to get to 100.
and James I think James was 94 here
um James J was 94. so we're so close to
100 members on patreon
um
we're less than six less than six people
to a hundred
which I know it seems kind of trivial
it's kind of weird
but it's it's like a round number and
and I want to thank all the audience
because without you watching without you
listening and just I wouldn't have the
ability
to even dream of having a hundred
members on patreon so I know it seems
small but
um it means a lot to me and it's big to
me so thank you very much we're so close
yeah like six away so if you if you want
to go check out patreon just go to
patreon.com
Michaels you can go to the
tonymichaels.com the mods will have it
uh the links in the chat there I know
they will and I appreciate all your
support and it means so much when we get
to 100 and I'll do a little celebration
it looks like probably tomorrow
is when we'll get there maybe tomorrow
during the show and maybe it's before
then I I don't know I don't know but I
just want to say thank you before I move
on and destroy this
Petty Yeti Marjorie Taylor green this is
um so she tweets this video
out of the president of the United
States
visiting Ukraine
in Kiev as um
Russians discover that Biden is there
and they release migs to try to um
to try to get the air raid sirens so
it'll scare the present and he doesn't
Flinch I'm going to show you that I'm
going to show you that
um oh uh
Joy Leaf I think is the um also joined
thank you very much
um for that
we're just we're again they're they're
coming in like like hotcakes here on the
patreon
um so she says here it is here it is
presents day 2023 okay
all right
you got me you you got me on the
President's Day 2023 it's President's
Day 2023. you got
oh thank you oh
I don't know why why did she start the
Tweet like that
yeah and she put a period it's not a
sentence but she put a period
um and maybe she's just you know
putting spaces and automatically pay you
know maybe
but she said zelinski can't even wear a
tie as he greets the bridge of the
United States okay all right now I see
what this is about I see
I see what this tweet is
okay she goes on to say he gladly takes
our money in sweatshirts and t-shirts
but Biden is dressed up so insulting
America last
hey Marjorie
it's a war
they're in a war
I'm sure that he's trying to show his
countrymen that he understands he's in a
war do you know what war is Marjorie do
you have any idea what war is
do you have any glue because you're on
the you're on the committee for uh
Homeland Security I hope I hope
yeah she didn't she didn't know
are you kidding me come on
you think she knows what war is
give me a break
I can't stand her oh my God
um oh Hal Sparks commented let's see
what Hal said we got a lot of sparklers
in here
uh anyone has sparkler shout out in the
in the chat
houses
um why don't you get mad
go soak your head you goofy
oh
God damn Hal Sparks
um well I'm trying to like it and it's
not there and there it goes
I don't know why light are unliked
let's thank him for his tweet I know you
guys are sparkler fans
I know you guys are sparkler fans out
there I see you
oh Hal Sparks okay um
I gotta tell her her tweets I already
did I tell her tweet sucks your Tweet
sucks
your Tweet sucks I think towel for his
when I told her her tweet sex okay uh
let's see I think there's another clip
so we're in a dude I really thought I'd
get more into Marjorie Taylor green
there now here's the video here it is
this is the one I want to talk about
uh I said and just about the only clip
you need to see of the present of being
a defender of liberal democracy strength
you know I talk a lot about about
liberal democracy being strength
authoritarian and being the weakness now
this uh here you can obviously see this
is a dark Brandon here in the middle
dark Brandon here and then president
zielinski walking
beside dark Brandon
this isn't Joe Biden this is the uh this
is the dark Brandon body double I'm sure
that's what kiwanan's saying
um that no it's not that that's not
really do bad because what happens here
is it really tears down this whole
notion that Joe Biden is somehow weak
and feeble and he's scared and
uh I just watch and I'll explain it
[Music]
you hear the sirens in the background to
play it one more time let's play one
more time as they walk out here out in
the open Watch
[Music]
you notice that's an air raid sound
the reason why and it's in the Tweet
here
McDonald has it here he says if the
Kremlin thought launching a MIG and
Belarus triggering a nationwide air raid
alert because they know a certain type
of attack
is gonna trigger an air raid alert
right they know that
and they do it just as Biden's coming
out again I know all the Q and honors
and all right they're gonna be like yeah
that was really bad
that was a buddy Dibble them leftists
them Walkers call it dark Brandon hey
you know what
I'm not one to spread conspiracy
theories here
Maybe
maybe just maybe
there is a Joe Biden and there is a dark
Brandon
maybe they're right I'm just I mean you
know I don't
I don't want to seem like a chucklehead
here but God damn I mean maybe they're
right maybe there is
maybe there is a dark Brandon maybe
there is I don't know
and Joe Biden's different guy who knows
it could be maybe they're on the
something I'm just you and it's
the same dude it's the same dude
um
he goes on to say during the U.S
President Joe Biden's visit to the
country
would be intimidating but they're wrong
the background sound makes Biden look
Brave and based and Putin Petty and
impotent
and that's because uh he is petty and
impotent because he's a dictator he's
weak he's a weak authoritarian
authoritarianism is weak it's weak sauce
little dick energy they're
cucks
and let's watch this one more time I
think this is one of the this is going
to go down as one of the craziest
clips
in the context of it
and think about it think about this this
context that the United States President
because you damn well know that secret
service does not want Joe Biden walking
out in the open like this with these air
raid signs going on
they don't want but he don't give a
again this is the dark Brandon body
double and dark brand and body double
don't give two
if there's air raid sirens going on
he's got his he's got his shades
on he's got the aviators on and he's
gonna March through the whole thing
without a without even acting like those
things are going off
and really honestly if this was if this
was an attempt by Russia and Putin to
make Biden look weak ooh boy you
that went over like a white wet fart and
a white thong holy let's watch it
again
[Music]
beautiful
foreign
seems like liberal democracy is the
strength here in this in this um in this
picture someone says oh my God a wet
fart and a white thong yeah that when if
if Putin's goal was to scare zielinski
and Biden in this clip if that really
was the goal that went over like a wet
fart in a white thong
not good Susan not good at all
and um maybe someone can check it but if
you go to the merch store store I've
never really
uh said this I never promoted this on
the show but I actually believe there's
a t-shirt on there it's brown
t-shirts Brown and I believe on the
T-shirt it says
that went over like a wet fart and a
white thong I'm not you I
wouldn't you you're my favorite
turd I'd believe I I'm gonna check it
right now I'm almost sure
I'm almost sure of it
I mean I'm wrong
I have a design I'll put that some
up but I'm almost Bonzo let's see
let's see it did it do where are you
I know it's in here somewhere
yep there it is holy
uh hang on hang on I'm gonna show it to
you
I'm gonna show it to you
this is this is one of my favorite it's
one of my favorite phrases
okay
here's the website here's the emerge
store right
and here's the
here's the design
see if I can zoom in it's going over
like a wet fart in a white thong
oh
God damn
if you want one of these
just let me know if you want other stuff
like a sticker or coffee my God I'll
I'll put it over there too but I had to
make the T-shirt
it's going over like a wet fart in a
white thong Everyone likes that that
thing so go if you want your your wet
fart white thong t-shirt
it's called wet fart t-shirt by the way
that's the name wet fart t-shirt in dark
chocolate dark I don't name the color
they name the color you can get another
goes you can get in Black here
you know you can get it in Gray
there it is and there it is in the
midnight navy
I'm a chucklehead
I mean what are you gonna do what the
you gonna do what are you gonna do
what you gonna do
if I say something you might get I'll
throw that on a t-shirt I'll do it
every time okay um
let's get back to um the task at hand
here
we're getting off we're getting off
topic
talking about shirts someone asked me
earlier if I've ever shared it in public
what do you think what do you think now
someone says only from the Tony Michael
show yeah of course
of course of course where else are you
going to get commentary like this I
meant it some people dropped off the
broadcast did you did everyone go buy a
goddamn uh what are white wet fart thong
the T whatever it is and a bunch of
people dropped off the broadcast here I
feel like everyone's going to buy a
oh maybe I turned them off with the
shark talk
Jan says she wants to see the thong do
you do you see that's the problem that
we have Jan it's the Republican Party
is kind of like the wet fart in the
white thong that's the problem that we
have
is the Republican party is the the wet
fart of the white thong of democracy
here in the United States
and that's the problem that we got
okay let's see so there's uh that video
um let's see
um oh yes
here is the clip remember I was talking
earlier about Sheridan Brown see if I
can get this
there we go
um about Sheridan Brown on state of the
union and CNN and he was talking about
Ohio and this and that and I said
um I said in the tweet I said stop
voting Republic in Ohio and a lot of
people got in the comments it kind of
mad at me but I don't give a you
know me I don't give a so let's
let's listen to this clip
and I'll explain why I said eat
everything that's happened here all the
cleanup all the drilling all the testing
all the hotels stays all of that is on
Norfolk Southern they caused it there's
no question they caused it with this
derailment because again they under
invested in their employees by laying
they're my understanding they're only
three full-time people on that 50 I
might have been more than 50 car train
that went through town because they've
laid off so many people and I mean
that's why I'm angry when I look at
these companies lay people off they
never look out for their workers they
never look out for their communities
they look out for stock BuyBacks and
dividends something's wrong with the
corporate America and something's wrong
with Congress and administrations
listening too much to corporate Lobby
okay so let's oh Mary's got it on the
head now there's always going to be
corruption and greed incorporation and
capitalism you're not going to get rid
of that you listen listen to me if your
goal is to get rid of capitalism you're
you're not
you're not based in reality okay I get
that it sounds great to destroy
capitalism and get rid of it and you
know I get it sure you're not gonna do
that
it's not gonna happen not not in the
near future and I'm talking about within
the next 150 years you're not going to
destroy capitalism in this country
you're just not
you're not gonna do it
so what you have to do is regulate
capitalism to make sure it doesn't
destroy
average people's lives
inadvertently there's and there's
certain things that regulate and keep uh
corporate corporate corporations and
capitalism accountable one of those
things is labor unions I don't know if
you know the birth of labor unions I'm
not sure if you know this you should go
look that up
of the birth the labor unions in this
country
and you should go look up what labor
unions had delivered to this country now
I don't even say the right words labor
union a lot on this show because I don't
think I have to
to get people to understand the
importance of what they trade for their
salaries most Americans don't have
capital okay they don't have liquid
Capital most people don't have enough
money to rub together to make
enough money off of
it's not how this kind of country
fundamentally works it's not how
cannibalism works it's not how it works
but what you do have in this country
with the majority of Americans have in
this country
is to trade their labor for money
that is the capital that you have it's
not money Capital it's time Capital
human capital production capital
see they just they cannot they cannot
operate
without humans no matter what you say no
matter what AI does there never ever
ever is going to be a time
where they can build it without us
now
will they build it with less of us
that's up to you that is up to you
it's up to you
rather you whether you make sure our
government between us the people
holds corporations and capitalisms
accountable to us the citizens and not
only that we make them share our GDP
with us this idea that the one percent
get the to take the
entire that's our GDP too
do you know how much labor is traded
every single day in this country do you
have any idea how much labor is
traded in this country to get that GDP
they don't get to own it
I think I think the one thing that the
pandemic taught us more than anything is
that
Americans finally understood that oh my
God
I shouldn't thank my employer for my job
my employer should be thanking me
that I give them their late my labor for
the price they pay
right now rather rather you are a member
of a union or not
that sentiment Remains the Same
right
so or should I mean we kind of lost our
way in the 80s and 90s especially in the
early 2000s when Republicans really
really smashed up unions with right to
work and all that
all that nonsense that helps
capitalism and helps corporations take
your money your GDP and
they get to set high on the hog why you
give away your labor for nickels
pennies and dimes
this is not this is not rocket science
it's not and there's only one
group of people in this
country that are willing to stand up and
fight for workers rights now you'll get
commentary from tyt and and David Pacman
more t-y-t oh well Democrats are the
reason Democrats did this Democrats did
that blah blah blah yakety
schmackity when they're not paying
attention to the party and the president
who has been more pro-union than any
other president in the history
in our modern history
it is our job ours the government us
we the people to regulate and hold
corporations accountable
it is up and to regulate them it is up
to us
now we can't be the day-to-day that's
why we call we build things called the
bureaucracy
bureaucracy is not bad everyone oh man
the red tape and the bureaucracy Jesus
Christ boy I I really wish I really wish
I could load up my train cars full of
chemical poison
and haul it on down the track without
having to spend so much Goddamn money on
safe safety protocols not only that I
can't believe that I have to hire a
certain amount of people to make sure
that that train operates safely it's
just ridiculous you catch my
drift
do you catch my drift
now again everyone wants to blame the
company that spilled this thing
which they have responsibility
why do you think the wine does not want
the federal government sticking their
nose in this the reason why dewine does
not want their federal government stick
their nose and it's because the federal
government is going to make those
be accountable
that's why the Wine's like nope don't
want your help sorry you get away
our donor class does not want you to
hold this Corporation accountable for
this spill we want to blame it on you
uh Sean Hannity has been spilling uh
spreading this lie let me see if I can
find that
oh I had some clips of Ann Coulter too
that are really good
we just run out of time oh and
these tweets from Fox News
speaking on that God damn we just get
there's just too much you know that
there's just too much to go through
uh let me see if I can find this um
no no that's not it I'm trying to find
the clip of um you know what maybe
maybe I'll have to do an extended rant
sometime this week on these uh tweets
are these text messages from Fox News
that might be super important
um to get to Midas Touch you know we're
affiliated with them and put these out
where in the hell is the Sean Hannity
Ohio Hannity Ohio I keep spreading the
line well Fox News likes to spread
lights that's what those text messages
are about now I mean likes the spread
lines here it is decoding Fox News if
you're not following uh decoding Fox
News let me show you her account here
please go follow her decoding Fox News
it's at decoding Fox News she watches
Fox News so you don't have to
um she does a great job she she she
watches
um foxy just like Aaron acen but you
should follow her as well she she has
some other clips than what they have
this is from Hannity
um Lee zeldon uh uh is the got this
chucklehead that's going to be
talking here
um he's the one who lost the New York
Governor's race uh but you know what I I
just want to point out for Marjorie
Taylor green I don't know marjorie's
watching it I told you to listen today
you you troglodyte Petty Yeti
um Sean Hannity doesn't have on a tire
how how disrespectful it
is that Sean Hannity appears on this
traitor TV News Network okay let's
let's uh let's let's listen to what
these chuckleheads have to say and then
we'll break it down Pete says that it's
Trump's fault they want to blame
regulation changes from years ago as
opposed to taking any responses no rules
on the show yeah and uh Senator Vance
credit to him okay the law that that
pothole Pete was referring to you know
was passed in 2015. okay this is this is
the stupid line that they keep
saying there was a law passed in
2015. under if you remember who the
president was in 2015 it was um
uh what was it it was that scary black
guy that they hate that led to racism in
this country being overt and the quiet
part out loud the reason why Fox News is
what it is today because oh yeah Barack
Obama the one with the scary name you
know him oh scary name yeah they hate
that guy they hate that guy and they
hate that he passed the law that
regulated emergency braking systems for
rail cars that were carrying toxic
chemicals let me let me repeat this
2015 this law that they're talking about
okay you following me that he keeps
spreading the lie about what's passed by
Obama
it was to regulate the word regulate is
very important there not deregulate to
regulate the braking systems on rail
cars that carried toxic chemicals the
same rail cars that this was carrying
they weren't deregulating it they were
regulating it so they use a kernel of
truth right this is what the these
do
they use something that is true yes in
2015 there was a law passed that had to
do with braking systems of rail cars
that carry toxic chemicals
it was actually in the form of
regulating it
under the Trump Administration they
undid those regulations they undid them
he used executive power to make sure
that corporations who operate rail cars
that carry toxic chemicals do not have
to run under the guise of the
regulations that would require them to
spend more money on expensive braking
systems that would I don't know if a
train was going through a town and
spilled over would keep that town safe
it was Trump
okay and they keep spreading the LIE
they keep spreading the lie do
you do you see what I'm trying to tell
you about narrative and messaging you're
gonna see this stupid this
stupid lie posted all over
social media all over social media is
going to be in your comments
they're gonna be in your face
about it
Obama did it it was so bad and that
shrimp it was passing 2015. you know
Obama was President that's the stupid
they're gonna say
because how information works and the
war that we're in with information
they are louder than we are
get loud about this
if you're pissed off about Ohio it is
not it is not
it is not the corporation's fault
I know you want to blame it on it is not
Joe Biden's fault it is not Obama's
fault it is the people of Ohio who
elected Donald Trump twice who
voted in JD Vance says the United States
Senator and have the wine as the
governor Ohio stop voting Republican
what don't you understand
Georgia stop vote Texas Missouri
Iowa Kansas Oklahoma
stop voting Republican stop it
you're pissed off about the old thing in
Ohio it's it's because of Republicans
listen if this Corporation was bound by
the regulations to buy and to spend the
money to have the braking systems on
these rail cars that carry these toxic
chemicals they would have bought them
and spent the money to have these cars
to have the braking systems if they were
so regulated by the federal government
they would have done it because it is in
their profits interest to haul that
toxic chemical on a rail car
through Ohio
it is in our interest to make sure they
do it responsibly
us the people the people in Ohio it is
our responsibility to each other
that they do it responsibly because they
won't if they don't have to they will if
they're forced to
just doubt me on this and again
I know the instinct is to blame
capitalism and blame corporations
it is the failure of us
we are at fault all of us
if we do not look internally and go hey
we that one up holy sorry
Ohio we really that one up
oh man and the people in Ohio who voted
for Republicans should be saying to the
people in that town
East Palestine uh we really that
up for you God damn whoo buddy we
that up sorry about that I can't believe
we
we lost our minds and voted for people
who didn't give a about us
oh man
listen the result that you're gonna get
if you elect people who care more about
the corporations than they care about
the people
who trade their labor and support those
corporations what result do you think
you're gonna get
what result are you think you're gonna
get
and here here you go here's here's Laura
on YouTube
and I get what Laura's saying here she
says Tony Ohio uh voters voted to get
rid of gerrymandering but the
Republicans also said screw the voters
they kept doing it anyways we can't get
rid of the repubs because it's so rigged
listen I get it I know what you're
saying why do you think I keep saying
let's rig blue States
do you know do you know what happened do
you want to happen if we rigged blue
States
doing what happened and if we rigged the
numbers to where we made DC in Puerto
Rico
states do you have any idea do you have
any idea if Democrats leaned into that
narrative leaned into that messaging I
mean Jesus Christ the Republican listen
listen you think oh my God oh my God oh
my God we can't do that Tony Jesus
Christ that would make us just like them
yeah it sure would
you have any idea how weak and how
feeble
these Republicans are when it
comes to democracy oh my God
Mark Elias just walks in a room
and they lose their minds
can you imagine
if the pro-democracy Coalition in this
country
decides collectively
through our narrative and our messaging
that what we're going to do is we're not
just gonna play defense with Mark Elias
we're going to go on offense
oh you want a gerrymander in Ohio
okay all right that's good we're gonna
gerrymander the out of New York
California you ain't gonna have
republican from north to south
oh you you you like you like
that Arizona didn't elect any Statewide
Republicans well we're going to do away
with that now that we got Statewide
Republicans we're going to gerrymander
the out of Arizona
and I'm not just talking in the national
elections
I'm talking counties state state
legislators you gerrymander the
ever loving out of it and you
threaten it and you move to do it I
don't even give a if Mark Alliance
listen listen to me very carefully
turn it up I'm going to say something
that's going to piss a lot of you off
I don't even give a if Mark Elias
has to come into a state and defend that
State against Democratic gerrymandering
I don't give a and if Mark Elias
has to come defend that state defend
that state and its constituents against
Democratic gerrymandering maybe
Republicans will just learn a
lesson
that we're not gonna lay down
for our democracy we're going to go to
every single link even the links they're
willing to go to destroy it to save it
so this idea that we can make excuses
for ourselves about Ohio being
gerrymandered and our Congress and Our
House of Representatives that's why
Kevin McCarthy is barely the speaker
and name only
that's our excuse to not do
something about the national narrative
National machine that is
ridiculous and Laura Laura I agree with
you I know the gerrymandering's a
problem
and we can deal with it
we can do it but what we have to do is
we have we have to battle it in the
Civil War that we're in and the Civil
War that we're in is information it's
the most important key here and if you
don't see that is what Sean Hannity and
Lee zeldon know you're a bone-headed
they know that's they know what they're
doing they know they're lying
they don't care
they don't care and you shouldn't care
to tell the truth
and the truth isn't the truth is not
that it's just rigged and there's no way
for democracy to win in Ohio that's
that's all 100
it's the people of Ohio that have not
collectively decided
that they don't want inept politicians
anymore who destroy their communities
that is that is what has happened and
because no one will stand in
front of a microphone and tell the
truth
so what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do
are you gonna fight
this Civil War of information
are you gonna sit back and let them win
because you're not willing to
participate because it's already rigged
why do you think I rail against David
Pacman and tyt that's why I rail against
them this this mindset that it's all
rigged and it's it's done anyway so who
gives a we can't win an Ohio bull
Sheridan Brown the center I just
showed he's a Democrat he's a goddamn
United States senator of Ohio he could
win
it's all in your mind cell set if you
self-suppress You're Gonna Lose
and telling people oh both sides are the
same ah it's rigged anyways Tony that's
tyt's mentality
and that's not that's not fighting for
the people stop fighting for democracy
that's not pro-democracy to be quite
honest with you that's anti-democracy
and Democrats have done it long enough
long enough
and the reason why I fight and I stand
in this fight and I'll continue to stand
in this fight against information in
this country
and I stand on the pro-democracy side of
this Civil War as opposed to
authoritarianism because that's your
Choice democracy
authoritarianism
the reason why I stand on this side and
not though I'll just give up will the
authoritarians take over because it's
rigged it's because it's worth
the fight every last inch of it
every last inch is worth it so I
appreciate you coming here and watching
Laura I appreciate it and one of these
days I know it a click and you'll say
you know what Tony is right it's not
rigged it's not right it's only rigged
in my brain it's only rigged and that
that person's brain this person's brain
that person's brain and if it gets
unrigged and all these brains
maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
democracy will win and you'll win by
coming and watching me every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube Twitter and twitch you're not
going to want to miss it I'm
telling you so subscribe to
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube it's
free to subscribe free doesn't
cost you a thing also it's free to go
over to Twitter and follow at Tony
Michaels pod and it's free to download
every single episode all two hours every
single weekday on Apple Spotify Google
please do me a favor even if you watch
this live or if you're watching replay
go download it listen to the first 30
minutes or just go to your favorite part
and re-listen on the audio version while
you're cooking or something
do me that favor also go to to hey if
you got an Amazon Prime account do you
have an Amazon Prime account
if you do go to Twitch download the App
log in to your Twitch app with the
Amazon Prime account because you get one
free subscription this is free too this
is all free you already have an Amazon
Prime account you can go log into twitch
now you have to do it every month
so you guys just go every month and and
you get the one free subscription you
can subscribe to the Tony Michaels
channel on Twitch it helps us out here
at the show Amazon kicks into our
Channel it doesn't cost you a single
dime if you're already a Prime member so
if you're a Prime member go along in on
Twitch and also follow the upwire.com
it's a new YouTube channel with content
creators over there we're airing our
show live on the up wire YouTube channel
is good upwire.com you find it there and
follow us on Facebook hey if you're out
there on the mind it says Facebook page
come on follow me too at the Tony
Michaels I put all my videos and stuff
up over there so you can follow me there
and oh boy tomorrow's Tuesday you know
what that means Texas Paul gave Sanchez
will be joining us again tomorrow
it's gonna be a great day until tomorrow
same time same place Surf's Up
you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
them em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon